Họ thận nhất hiện và khoảng sản chế lượng giống Mỹ và ổ suy lia đánh giống bước đi mới trong nỗ lực tại định印 chủi của mừng vàn tầu.
khi Washington tìm cách sản phục thuận vòng vòng nguồn tự Trung Quốc,
nếu ý kiến về sự kiện khi kết thoại thận này, bắt kinh và nữ thành trọng.
Hẳng định việc hình thành chủi sản xuất của mừng, và giữa trọng của thị trường và sự hợp tác hồn định dễ cơ cuo ra.
Giới phân tinh nhận định, thật thận này mạng như thế chế lợp, nhưng chưa đủ để làm suy giảm bị thấy thống chỉ của Trung Quốc.
Cô ra đánh kiểm soát phần lớn sản luận chế biến nhất hiếm.
Mỹ cần thêm thời gian gần gệ và tài chính, để sư dân chủi của mừng độc lập.
Chúng bất cảnh xuất hầu năm trong đất hiếm của Trung Quốc sang Mỹ,
giảm hai tháng li bếp, của cảnh trang trong lý bật tành huyên quan trọng này,
được dự báo sẽ còn kéo dài và phức tạc hơn.